Reggie Miller part of NBA all-star
weekend festivities in Chicago he'll be
on the call for the rockets warriors
this Thursday night at 10:30 Eastern on
TNT alongside Kevin Harlan and Kristen
Ledlow I guess with the common theme of
the player introductions have this one
offered up from one of our listeners Jim
Whistler his three-point shot was so
deadly
they called him a killer here's
five-time all-star Reggie
Aloysius Miller that's right forget
comment yeah I've been I've been a part
of the NBA in the Turner family for the
last 14 years that was absolutely the
best hands down intro that I've been a
part of they didn't have anything like
that when I played but you know let's
face it it's the all-star game is I
would say have entertainment and half
the game right that was the best intro
because common was on point and
everyone's asking did he have a
teleprompter up there and I tell them
who cares I don't care if he had a
teleprompter or not his cadence and his
delivery and the short rhymes were on
point so he really said that I think him
along with Jennifer Hudson yeah they set
the mood the tone for the game I thought
Chaka Khan was fantastic as well you and
I were shockers era we grew up with her
music her stick in the national anthem
the tone was set and I thought the game
delivered when it had to all right did
you know it was gonna be that intense
because I looked at the stats here reg
and I don't know if you're aware of this
but first quarter players combined to
shoot 62% they shot 48 percent in the
second quarter 57 percent in the third
quarter they shot 35 percent in the
fourth quarter dunk 23 in the first
quarter 12 in the second 13 in the third
three in the fourth fouls
two in the first five in the second
seven in the third 21 in the fourth
blocked shots
one in the first two in the second
quarter four in the third and seven in
the fourth its there's a theme that
something was forming as the night went
on look no one really knew what to
expect in this new this new format once
the game started I think grant and in
marv and we kind of looked at each other
was like oh here we go again
the first two quarters I think the guys
were kind of feeling their way through
LeBron won the first quarter for his
charity Yanis won the second quarter for
his charity and they went to halftime
I'm thinking okay alright
both teams there's got money for the
charity now it's time to go and I think
you saw the level of play step up the
start of that third quarter and
certainly that fourth quarter was the
best basketball I know people were like
there were so many fouls and you know
obviously fouls
I look guys were putting their bodies up
Kyle Lowery was putting his body his
career on the line standing in front of
LeBron James coming down hill are you
kidding me I didn't want it to end on a
free throw and and if people thought
this was gonna speed up the game it
didn't the fourth quarter was 45 minutes
long but I did like that could you ever
see the NBA adopting this during the
regular season
I don't think so during the regular
season I think for an exhibition
glorified pickup game like this was it
was fantastic
I know people are probably a little bit
upset by ending on a free throw but they
knew all along what your target number
was by any means necessary get to that
target number sometimes you've got to
play defense without fouling I think I
kept highlighting that once they hit 136
you've got to play defense without
fouling and they got caught on a switch
with collar e down low against Anthony
Davis and he had no choice but to follow
the slam dunk contest help me out here
help me help me understand what was what
was going on behind the scenes and if
you had to vote today between those two
who gets your vote I would give it to
them both
and I kept saying this on air I thought
the judges they set the tone in the mood
that's whatever scores they gave out
they set the tones by giving out those
50s early so a lot of those dunks I
wouldn't say we're similar but they were
close to nature so if one got fifty the
other had to get fifty right you
couldn't go above so you I don't care
about them giving out a lot of fifties
but the tone had been set so uh to me I
would have walked off the podium and
look we've had all-star game Finals MVPs
before right we've had co rookie of the
years before why can't we have a co slam
dunk champion well here's something I
don't know if this has ever been brought
up but why not have nine point six or
nine point eight not everything is a ten
not everything's a 50 you're right
and I believe that you used to have
something like that kind of like the you
know the Olympic judge yes in gymnastics
I agree because some like the Pat
Connaughton dunk could have been like an
eight point five or not you know yeah it
could have been something like that
which look when you jump over a seven
five dude and you've had 50s across the
board I just don't see how you lose I
don't see how you can lose that so to me
they should have shook hands and we'll
share the championship a bobby fischer
line but I Darren let me get let me say
this to Derrick Jones jr. deserves the
win as well because he was spectacular
so I don't want to rain on his parade
because he is the slam dunk champion but
I'm still scratching my head how you can
have 50s across the board jump over a
seven five dude and not have any
hardware at the end of the day well why
were the judges reportedly conspiring to
make it a tie why not I mean just look I
think you know I kept it honest we we
kept waiting wait a little bit honest I
think they didn't want that
responsibility because if they would
have given Aaron Gordon a 50 and it
would have been another tie they would
have had to decide those five so
obviously it would have been a three-two
you would have had your champion by then
I don't think they wanted that to come
down to them which is unfortunate that's
that's my only reasoning and thinking
behind that but you jump over a
seven-five dude and you have 50th across
the board he deserved to win what about
the play with Trey young going between
the legs of James Harden
can you imagine a young guy like a
second-year guy doing that to you like a
year the nutmeg as they call it and he's
done it in games throughout the year but
he usually does that against big men
rarely will you see a guy on James
Harden level a guard you normally don't
see that that does because James Harden
has done that to players before so I was
a little surprised he did that and that
kind of showed the first two quarters
you know they were kind of going through
the motions and everyone was crushing
their head like oh god here we go again
but it's a sweet play but I will say
this if I'm one of those bigs and he did
that to me I would let him go all the
way to the hole and he's gonna be out
about a week right he's gonna be out
about a week you know who looked out of
place last time they're two guys joking
and James Harden looked out of place in
a format like that I think well if you
from Joker standpoint it's it's an
glorified up and down game yeah right
and his style of play is throw it to me
in the post do a whole bunch of cutting
either I'm gonna you know pass the ball
to you I could knock down a three it's
not really his style of game James
Harden probably hit the biggest shot
that three in the corner to tie the
ballgame
I believe to go up three so I think he
came on late again it's an all-star game
yeah I'm applauding how that fourth
quarter I've never seen so much dialogue
with the officials in an all-star game
maybe ever and it shows you this sense
of urgency and I don't know if you could
tell by watching the game at home but
the two charities that were side by side
in zone that was awesome
they were they were going at it which
like added to the hype in the building
so that was kudos to whoever thought of
that to have I mean it was brilliant
you know team Yannick and team LeBron
and that fanbase going at one another it
just added to the drama inside that
building do you cross paths with anybody
interesting at the all-star festivities
it was star said it wasn't it yeah I
mean it took me back a few things
because Donnie Wahlberg
I remember when and I'm going to tell
you about age like with new kids on the
block again that's your no and I stopped
and I yes it is no it's not no okay your
girls how about this your girls right in
that way no new kids on the block stop
it my boy band was the Osmonds and the
Jackson father okay my boy been with the
Jackson 5 okay you're right okay alright
so Donnie Wahlberg and New Kids on the
Block what yes back in the day and
Market Square would neighbor come
through I mean he asked me to go on
stage with it was crazy back there like
some of the stories he went on stage
with new kids on the find that find that
that picture of reg on stage with new
kids on the block
alright thank you they might be poor
learning for that who else did you run
into cardi B swung by the the broadcast
station Queen I love Queen Latifah lover
lover lover so it was always great when
the celebs come by and give a shout out
and Theodore you need my dance you and
the dance need to come to Indiana next
year once you guys like you treat it
like it's a Super Bowl treat it like
it's a Super Bowl and come to Indiana
and just hang out to my adopted home
state y'all have to show some love do
you still have a crib there I do not but
we could all here see together
yeah but if Shaq goes into the bathroom
and that's not going to be good that
would be great the theater will have the
studio show with Jack Charles Ginny and
Ernie and it will just all be in a house
it will just livestream it like Big
Brother okay
was Michael Jordan there I did not see
him no I don't think he was there no
because I saw they did that that video
that was that the open how cool was that
open talking about Chicago yeah I mean
reg they they tried to claim Kevin
Garnett with Chicago yes he was there
for a year and a half when he went to
he's not from Chicago
well yeah but Mike yeah I'm okay with
that one but Kevin Garnett I went late
he's from South Carolina I buy that
black hat in Chicago so our city of
Chicago in there hello did you have to
pay taxes for every city that you went
into really yeah yes for the IRS
listening yes I paid my taxes yes and
what then you had a couple of states
that didn't have in content well and
then you had a couple states that you're
there quite often like in New York we
were there a lot because of playoffs
other than two times you go there during
their regular season so there are some
states that you know that tax you look
like what what if you don't play but you
go with the team like you that still
counts right because you're you're still
in that state for a game you know that
picture of Uncle Sam saying no by the
way Jordan turns 57 today
happy birthday black Jesus number 23 you
know I hate calling him Michael Jordan I
hate saying Michael Jordan because
there's a lot of other names I can't say
on air that I affectionately call him
but the great he's look to go OK and we
just celebrated you know our great
athletes in our game today in the
all-star game but he to me he stands
above everyone else and I thought I
might be cool the one thing that really
struck me is the impact that Kobe had on
these younger players because as we like
to say he was there Jordan and Kobe's
impact influence on these young younger
players is really remote orden didn't do
what Kobe did he wasn't reaching out to
try to you know make these guys better
you know hey you want to pick my brain
like Kobe really relished that I think
he loved that the science the you know
that approach to being great and the
fact that these guys every one of them
had a story about Kobe but also to Kobe
was the start of social media in the
height of it and he used that to
advantage if MJ was you know we've been
a part of the social age and media and
tik-tok in Instagram and Twitter he
would be just as big but I know but I
don't know he would have been sharing
secret what no no right well I tried I
tried when he was shooting Space Jam and
we'd go up to the Jordan Dome to play
after he I still don't understand how he
did this he would shoot from 6 a.m. to
about 7 p.m. and then he summon us the
king would summon us to come play
basketball they built a dome they called
it the Jordan dome on the set of I think
that was paramount and MGM whatever it
was yeah
they built a basketball and we would all
come run from like 9:00 to like midnight
and dance we're all like I'm gonna I'm
gonna find it I'm going to find the
tails I'm gonna find it
weaknesses this is gonna be great he's
not going to know what I'm doing and
every time they were picked teens I'm
like no I want to be on opposite no I'm
obviously MJ with the same position if
you get you know for us to go out one
another yeah I mean I couldn't find us
not one not one I got two more
introductions for you before I let you
go I hope you're not getting a cold here
you sound is it just because you were
talking so much this week okay over you
know D wait and it was a long weekend
but see I knew how important this was
our conversations on Monday I don't care
about my throat I care about that's
steam dredge you know while he's getting
ready for the three-point or the you
know three-point shooting contest no
they said yeah I said are you gonna
bring it up on the air of a former
player with a current player in the
three-point contest and what did you say
I said perhaps if it comes up yes I will
and then you said you can take credit
for it
yes I'm like no I don't steal things
from other people I don't know all right
here you go
he's one of the best shooters of all
time I can say that with no pretense but
on the other side of the ball my man
never played defense here's Reggie
Miller oh I cannot believe you just hurt
my okay I'm gonna I'm gonna hurt your
feelings again from beyond the arc my
man was real nifty when reg came into
the league he weighed a buck fifty safe
travels I was a was great watch great
list in the entire weekend and TNT did a
wonderful job reg will be on the call
for rockets in the Warriors Thursday
night at 10:30 Eastern on TNT Thank You
reg Theodore absolutely the best Danette
I love y'all Big Brother house Indiana
all-star 2021 that's Reggie Miller
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]